hey guys dr. Berg here in this video we're gonna
talk about the perfect exercise now what is the
perfect exercise it really is based on your body
so you have people that are completely out of
shape completely burnt out and any of those
people that are really top athletes so we're
gonna just teach you the elements so you can
adapt them to your workout it really exercises
composed of three simple variables we have the
time of exercise we have the intensity and then
we have the recovery and then you also can have
frequency and how many times you do it but that's
the simplicity of a workout now the question is
if you're going for toning or you're going for
fat-burning there's different things that you
can go for like for example if you're going for
toning you're going to be working in the body part
a little differently what I'm going to talk about
is mainly overall fitness and fat burning okay
it's how to maximize that so the first thing to
know is that the time of exercise is really not
something that increases growth hormone which is
the main fat burning hormone so in fact the more
you work out the more you increase cortisol the
more you add stress to the body so these people
that are doing that let's say the high-intensity
long duration hour hour and a half boot camp every
single day all they're doing is raising cortisol
they're not going to get fit they're not going to
lose weight so ideally to trigger growth hormone
you need shorter time higher full-body intensity
and lots of recovery that would be the best option
now let's first talk about intensity what kind of
intensity do I mean well anything that works your
every single muscle at one time that would be
the best thing like some people would do some
type of kickboxing aerobic type workout where
they're doing you know lower body and upper body
I like to do deadlifts in fact that really helps
my back when I do that but doing a good deadlift
with great technique you can get some serious
intensity because you're using every single muscle
that you have you can also do jump rope you can
do like certain types of yoga is very very high
intensity you know to work every single body so
we want to do something that spikes the pulse
rate fast and works all your body but we don't
want to do this for a long time but you want
to do it short now here's the here's the rule of
thumb the maximum time of workout if you're doing
interval training which is short high-intensity
rest short intensity high rest would be between
20 and 40 minutes any time you have to go over
40 minutes what that means is that you're going
to diminish your returns it would be much better
than increase the intensity so I like to do short
high-intensity rest but if you're just starting
out we're just getting into it 20 minutes every
other day is fine so what I'm talking about is
let's say you're gonna do some type of workout
where you would do a high intensity for 2 maybe
3 minutes maybe 1 to 3 minutes and then you would
rest for maybe 4 to 5 minutes versus if you're
doing like CrossFit which is way over training
for most people unless you're 18 years old this
whole thing with workout one minute on one minute
off does not work you're not going to have enough
recovery we want that pulse rate to come all the
way down I also do biking so I'll sprint for like
one to two minutes really hard my whole body and
then I'll rest in Coast for about 2 to 3 to 4
minutes and then I'll do it again and I'll do
that for 20 to 40 minutes every other day and
the off days I'll do walking so those are just
some rules of thumb because this will increase
growth hormone now the other value variable is
this recovery right here all the benefit from
the exercise occurs in that second recovery
stage primarily when you're sleeping and 48 to
72 hours later that's where all the good stuff
happens because you this is all just stress this
is all just rebuilding recovering fat burning and
that takes some time now with recovery if you're
doing high-intensity you have to be really good
shape to do that every day you may be wanting
to do that every other day now there are some
people that I work with that have to recover a lot
longer so I might have them do a high-intensity
workout and then recover for 4 to 5 days I had
people that I switched them from every other day
to once a week and man they start losing weight
like crazy so this is something you want to test
in your body to see if you're not losing weight
increase recovery and see if that doesn't help
you versus sacrificing your sleep getting up early
at 4 o'clock in the morning to get that workout
it's much better to get to sleep than it is to
workout because that's where all the good stuff
happens if you're overtraining by not sleeping
and working out too frequently you're not gonna
see any results and I have a lot of people I have
one lady she was working out 6 hours a day nothing
no results I mean she's overtraining but when her
mind she's thinking burning off calories but it
wasn't working so we want to play around with this
so in the recovery phase you got to make sure that
your stress is low you got to make sure you're
sleeping here to make sure you're not overdoing
it you're not eating incorrect things but a lot of
things food-wise can go into this too like if you
were to eat a little sugar or a little wine or a
little juice you're going to pretty much kiss that
benefit from workouts out the window for about
48 to 72 hours as well and I'll do another video
on that but the point is that there are things
that can screw it up hidden carbs a little bit
of sugar so this is um so what we want to do is
we want to shorten a time we want to increase the
intensity but you got to do it at a very gradual
pace because it's very easy to overdo it and hurt
yourself which I'm guilty of as well I'm like jump
right in and almost an end up with that you know
sprained ankle or something like that so we want
to do that and then the key is that let your body
recover I like to do every other day and see
if that works for most people so so those are
some variables but you want to play around and
see what what's best for you ok and also I have
a quiz down below take the evaluation quiz and
this quiz helps you to find out a lot of other
barriers that you might have that are stopping
you from getting healthy thanks for watching